[Musik]
wenn es ja die haben damit ihren
geschätzte gäste aber vor allem hier der
internetkunden ich darf euch recht
herzlich begrüßen zur angelobung des in
je nach eingerückten einigungstermin des
sogenannten ids nur 121 wiederum eine
angelobung unter kaserne hier
eingetreten 73 grundwehrdiener anzug
gelogen rekruten der zweiten aufführung
kompanie des aufklärungs und
artilleriebataillons 3 ebenfalls ein
fernzug gestellt durch soldaten der
stabskompanie unter ersten
aufklärungskampagne
musikalisch umrahmt wird diese
fertigkeit von der militärmusik
niederösterreich unter definierten
kommando von der kapellmeister
oberstedten dadurch obendrauf
ich schätze damen und herren lassen sie
mich kurz den weiteren ablauf erläutern
es wurde soeben das feldzeichen
übernommen da kommen ganz der
ausgerückten gruppe oberstleutnant eric
graf hat das feldzeichen einmarschieren
lassen nicht nur das feldzeichen des
aufklärungs und artilleriebataillons
dreieck ist hier angetreten sondern auch
die sterne des österreichischen
kameradschaftsbundes der start des
stadtverbandes mistelbach das
feldzeichen hat folgende bedeutung es
ist das symbol des kommandanten der
ausgerückten truppe in früherer zeit
zwar eine schlacht gewonnen wenn der
fans das feldzeichen die besitz nehmen
konnte ich schätze da haben sie an in
kürze beginnt der eigentliche festakt
mit dem ankündigungs signal unter
meldung an den tanz der dritten
jägerbrigade brigadier christian
habersatter im anschluss erzählt die
bundeshymne
das erfolgt das abschreiten der front
unter den klängen des präsentiermarsch
und die große flaggenparade musikalisch
umrahmt vom generals maschen
[Musik]
dann traf
aber ja die obersten ende das feld
verlassen baptista ist die gefahr nicht
verwandelt team sehr wohl recht erklären
damit holt sich eingenommen
[Musik]
was kein fett
wer das ganze parabel
wolfgang placke das ganze projekt
[Musik]
es sollten die ansprache des hausherrn
jetzt kommandanten des aufklärungs und
artilleriebataillons dreht die grußworte
von oberst hans peter honig und im
anschluss daran werden wir einen korb
meine herren regierten jemand ergänzt
jahr 2020 die weltraum in ihrem leben
vergewaltigt eine bank ein gesetz zu
beschreiben nun ihren grundwehrdienst
sondern weil ich auch wir massive
auswirkungen auf ihre lebensgewohnheiten
wie ich das höre ich bedanke mich das
nicht gewesen wäre
warum wird die entschieden haben heute
jeder dritten aus dem feiern wir wir
verlegen
angenommen sie wird in kürze
die meisten war werden wir heute in der
gemeinde objekten weil wir heute an
gegen dabei was ist schon normal
das war wirklich auch hier im livestream
im internet an wenigen auf ihre
angehörigen herzlich begrüßen und
aufgegangen ich kenne bereits ihre
leistungen
was sie jetzt die anklage auf ihre söhne
enkel verwandte bekannte stolz sein
können die leistungen waren bis jetzt
ausgezeichnet
ich glaube auch nichts passieren dass
einige ehrengäste eingeladen
danke sagen das ist natürlich eine
wertschätzung die frage sagt einige
ehrengäste namentlich begrüßen
ich hoffe sie uns da und damit
abschließen und einen applaus ich hätte
nichts gegen einen respektvollen großen
militärischen vorgesetzten reagiert man
ist aber sagt christian was ich sonst
stand an der spitze sowie ein dreher und
folglich herzlich begrüßen den innenhof
mit bekannten mit wir haben endlich als
jetzt
[Musik]
jetzt einsatz im einsatz organisation
begrüße der bezirksfeuerwehrkommandant
obr werner reinhardt zweiten landes
regierungsrat hier seinen neuen zusagen
waren chef der autobahnpolizei
chefentwickler martin ammann
die präsidentenwahlen maschen
[Musik]
auch die hier auch begrüßen der gäste um
einen applaus werden sollen rekruten
[Musik]
warten auf der eigens inszeniert
laut von sich geben die waffen sicher
auch für wochenende mussten den gegner
antreten
auf sie warten sicher nicht nur fakten
zu wissen wie macht sich bereits einige
male gesehen war der chef des
generalstabs general motors dann auch
die spediert und vor einigen
fernschüssen zugesehen schießwarts habe
die änderung die scherben und wir sind
einfach erschossen
dies erfolgt ich bin wirklich begeistert
von der feuerwehr vorwärts die auch
jetzt hier wie geht die volle leistungs
workshop beträgt sie werden uns nächste
woche dann mit freitag verlassen ich
darf ihnen beim bundesheer alles
erdenklich gute wünschen bleiben sie
umfang schreibt bleiben sie gesund
nochmals im kühlen bank und zeige sich
auch ihre leistung die nächsten fünf
monate
ich bin
stolz auf sie es lebe das klassische
bundes habe das abgehakt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die wohnung geworden militärischen
geistlichkeit für die
römisch-katholische kirche jeder bekam
alfred heinrich für die evangelische
kirche viele jahre rektor rohr bank
internat führen wird es liegt auf der
hand
guten rat fragen woher wissen testen sie
ihr selbst nehmen hier entwickelt diese
angenommen sie war gekommen
assistance mission kameraden und
aufgrund der katholische militärbischof
kennen werden dem leben kommenden
dienstag fragen getan wird ist die
blutigste für die mehrzahl und verwertet
die wir schon derzeit können von euren
eltern sagen was sie alles verbracht
haben in den ersten wochen warten
es war so wie das von insgesamt sind wir
sehr sehr deutlich 1000 euro
es war herausfordernd kontaktieren kann
überall aber die meisten
ich habe in diesem zusammenhang magische
gerät mit auf den weg geben und unser
heutigen tages lesen und habe ich das
camp verbringt ihr werdet es passt ganz
gut da erst lernen werden mehr als 250
welchen weg er zuversichtlich weg gehabt
das ist heute wie wir gehört abba rosen
aber wie soll diese geschaffen und er
werde es auch geschafft spüren wir das
zweite was ausdauer geschnitten was wir
zwar auch ist ausdauer damit wir den
dienst prozent oder bis wir dann
natürlich auch stets damit wird in
vielen gottes erfüllen können und so das
verheißene jugendamt es regelt das herz
der zuversicht nicht haben ausdauer
vermittelte dem gott sich sehr früh
erkennt wer unser land für unser aller
wohl und dazu wirklich weg
das widersprüchliche reaktionen auslöste
diese zuerst klingt auch hier für männer
dazu verleiten eine moral predigt zu
halten
die erhobenen zeigefinger auf der einen
seite des punkte auf der anderen seite
das böse das böse das bestimmt und
geschickt wird
aber was
oder ist das erlaubt uns in verbindung
mit menschen diese unterscheidung zu
schädigen und seine warnung
unsere offiziere waren
einschätzungsvermögen was kann mir
wirklich dabei helfen das gute wirksam
werden zu lassen wenn ich mit dem krisen
konfrontiert die evangelische theologie
meinte dazu dass sie die lösen wollten
könnten wenn wir die antwort auf fragen
wie was ist die wichtigste zeit im leben
welcher mensch ist der wichtigste im
leben des einzelnen und welches werk ist
das wichtigste im leben
er gab uns auf antrag nun die ich meine
richtige antworten
es gibt nur eine wichtigste zeit nämlich
den augenblick gegenwart ohne dass wir
vergangenes vergessen und zukünftiges
außer acht lassen
wenn ich meine gerade das letzte jahr
hat uns das nur einzelne mehr spürbar
gemacht
ob der augenblick ist auch der
wichtigste teil die wichtigste zeit weil
wir nur diese zeit über über gewalt
haben
das wird der wichtigste mensch ist der
mit dem tun im augenblick zusammen ist
denn nehmen kann ist mir je wieder mit
ihr mit ihm zusammen kommen und das
wichtigste wert ist
hier ein gutes zu tun darum sind wir
menschen diese welt geboren und gesandt
so langsam geht's in ihren diensten als
rekruten als vorgesetzter mendes mit in
eine familie und ich meine dann kann
auch das wunder geschehen dass eine jede
ein jeder von uns genug an frieden und
glück hat dass wir in unserem leben auch
so dringend brauchen
[Musik]
sollten die ansprache des bürgermeisters
der stadtgemeinde mistelbach wertvollen
ikonen der traditionsmarsch unseres
fortgesetzt ein anderes der fehrbelliner
reitermarsch
hohe geistlichkeit sehr geehrte
kommandant sehr gern ja eine konzessions
kommandant sehr geehrte fest vom kern
gestern soldatinnen die wir sogar vor
allem liebe angst die lobenden
angenommen wenn sie der gemeinde in
einer stadt stattfindet ist die man so
etwas werden verehrt haben nicht nur für
die betreffenden rekruten ist so etwas
noch einmal im leben erleben sondern
natürlich auch für alle ehrengäste
eingeladen sind und daher sehen wir ja
was gesagt hat selbstverständlich gerne
gekommen und haben womöglich andere
termine verschoben weil die zeiten wie
diesen etwas besonders ist etwas
erfreuliches ist ein junge der mit guten
ergebnis von gesprächen
ich bin auch sehr stolz dass ich hier
sein darf gerade bei misco baut nicht
nur einen statisten gesundheit wird
durch werbung der vorgenannten wird wer
alle wichtigen schulen
bildungseinrichtungen haben andere
einkaufen und wirtschaft gut
funktioniert sondern das ist vielleicht
etwas aus ihrer nicht haben weil wir
neben eine ganze und schmerzen
und macht mich besonders stolz hier
heute vor den rechten zu dürfen
sie beginnen nur 73 minuten
dass sie heute hier angelockt werden im
nächsten dorf und auch mir dass sie mist
gebaut wird erst in ihrem verdienst
verbringen und einen guten erinnerungen
geneigten vertreten woche nächste woche
zu verlassen sind los gleich respekt
aber sie haben sich schon auf die spuren
hinterlassen
im positiven sinne neulich bin ich vom
kantonsrat gehören viele leistungen bis
jetzt hervorragend ausgezeichnet war
charakters zum teil selbst geschrieben
persönlich kennenlernen und abtrünnigen
dass die zusammenarbeit mit ihnen
rothenkirchen sehr angenehm ich wünsche
ihnen auf ihren weg und dass diese
angenommen missbrauchstaten antworten
das ist auch ein besonderes erlebnis ist
aber sehr schwer
hoffmanns liebe gießen mit diesen lieben
jetzt vor den räten zu hause zu sehen
aber sie sieht vor dass man das hier
warten ich bedanke mich ausdrücklich bei
allen die mit möglich machen bewohner
trotz dieser schwierigen zeiten das ist
dieser festliche atmosphäre schwarzen
ich bedanke mich bei allen die die linie
die veranstaltung die eigentlich laden
haben besondere paramilitärs kriege ich
wünsche ihnen ein schönes wochenende
fahren und dann in mistelbach und alles
alles gute auf dem weiteren lebensweg
haben sie gesehen
[Musik]
es sollten die ansprache dass private
kommandanten der brite jägerbrigade
brigadier christian hassa
die geistlichkeit der bürgermeister die
ehrengäste ich darf auch begrüßen alle
diejenigen die zu hause sind und die
angelobung ihre verwandten söhne partner
freunde mitverfolgen
und ich darf mich auch bedanken dafür
ist und wie der musik ist und wir haben
da steckt die schätze guten umhängen
übungstermine jänner diesen jahres
sie werden heute die treue gelöbnis
ablegen
sie gehen damit eine besondere bindung
mit der republik mit dem
österreichischen volk
es ist nicht eine bindung zu personen
zufolge setzten zum patron skaten oder
wen auch immer es ist eine bindung und
erteilt den sie leisten auf dieser
republik das ist ein besonderes
verhältnis
das ein ganzes leben lang her sie werden
vermutlich einige jahre nach dem abriss
nicht mehr sehr daran denken aber diese
bindung zum spiel bleiben die ganzen
leben
sie gehen dieses
diese bingo einer besonderen zeit
wandeln
[Musik]
sie treten
unter diesen meine waidwerk bewältigen
verschiedene aufgaben letzter konsequenz
im bereich der militärischen
landesverteidigung zu erfinden
ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass ein dritter das bundesheer sich
sehr vieles wenig geändert also eine
richtige umstellung raus aus der familie
aus dem bekanntenkreis und ein system
das zwangsweise auf gewissen werden
aufbauen können wir funktionieren dieser
werke aufgelegt werden und das in
frankreich erleben
seine verhaftung bärischen ausrufen
umgang mit fahrzeugen oder erste hilfe
ausrüstung
sie sagen dass sie bei uns lernen
ich kann nicht nur wünschen dass sich
das wenigste wirklich
eine riesenhafte jetzt noch brauchen
aber wir dass davon auszugehen ist
sie kennen die wissen dass die deutsche
bevölkerung notwendig
[Musik]
das ist dieses jahr angeboten haben und
kaninchen unfallfrei liebsten monaten
bewältigen ist eine ausnahmesituation
bestehen wie kann in kalabrien ist die
ausbildung der jahre später noch daran
endlich gab
ich glaube dieser stelle allen
angehörigen die hoffentlich zu rufen zu
hause aus zuschauen können bedanken darf
sie aber bitten unsere kameraden
entsprechend zu unterstützen
diese unterstützung ist notwendig damit
dass hier noch die ausbildung also weit
entfernt und den eigenen unbedingt
durchgeführt werden kann und ich bedanke
mich beim karte personal des planes was
immer versucht versucht möglichst gut
die ausbildung zu planen durchzuführen
aber auch sehr gewissenhaft die
kameraden unsere jungen mitarbeiter
anzuleiten und zu begleiten
sechs der rekruten ich wünsche ihnen
viele gute eindrücke eine möglichst gute
ausbildung und eine grundwehrdienst den
sie sich noch lange erinnern sollen
es leben unsere rekruten vom
entwicklungsteam in jener es lebe das hp
das leben unserer republik österreich
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten herrn wir kommen nun
zum eigentlichen höhepunkt der heutigen
veranstaltung in kürze werden die hier
angetretenen rekruten das treuegelöbnis
sprechen
zu diesem zweck wird das feldzeichen
vortreten und die eingeteilten gruppen
jan hat trainer stockerau und martin
ausbaden
[Musik]
kannst du dir wirklich genau ich gelobe
mein vater sein
wir sind geprägt österreich und sind
wohl zu schützen zu schützen und mit der
maus verteidigen
wenn die gesetze gesetzlich treue und
gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle wenn der vorgesetzte die
sätze künstlich und geworfen zu gefunden
raase und mit allen kräften der republik
österreich unseren österreichischen volk
zu dienen
[Applaus]
die eingestellten rekruten dreht
verneinung des hochhauses weiteres
niederösterreichische landesrätin ist
das kapitel weitere befehle
welchen interessenten
[Musik]
danke
a
[Musik]
das ganze ihren zug
das ganze habe
das ganze ihre zu pressen
zur meldung us amerikaner kann man dann
das ganze
es wurden unter befehl arbeit abbringen
zu lassen
zuerst das feldzeichen wird
großmaschinen und im anschluss die
truppe abtreten
[Musik]